now we turn our focus back to Washington
DC the swamp where President Trump has
issued a stern warning to anyone
attempting to vandalize historic
monuments and buildings yesterday he
vowed to enforce the Preservation Act
and put any Vandals behind bars for up
to 10 years today during a speech in
Arizona just a couple of short hours ago
or an hour and a half ago the president
had this to say about some of the
far-left protestors causing massive
unrest in America's cities let's take a
look they're tearing down statues
desecrating monuments and purging
dissenters it's not the behavior of a
peaceful political movement it's the
behavior of totalitarians and tyrants
and people that don't love our country
they don't love our country
this comes as law enforcement in DC
faced yet another wave of a angry
protesters tonight police all across
this country continue to now face
horrific conditions we're now heading up
to 900 injured rocks bottles bricks
Molotov cocktails we have some debts of
many as 6/1 permanently injured and now
paralyzed from the neck down here's just
a small sample of what they are up
against take a look
as you can see not exactly the easiest
job in the world now despite what our
extreme conditions that police are
facing Democratic politicians they are
leaving them out to dry some even
calling for the entire police
departments and big cities to be
defunded and even dismantled now these
are the same Democratic politicians as
we went over in great detail last night
we won't reiterate tonight but to sum up
have failed their cities for decades
their education system in runes violent
crime has been out of control for
decades they don't solve or fix any
problem safety security for every
American should be a protected right and
in the past few weeks
a wave of looting arson vandalism
precinct burning precincts taken over
and wreck city centers so what is the
democratic presumptive nominees plan to
restore order in America's liberal
cities as we begin our opening monologue
tonight after all we do have another
candidate it is a hundred and thirty
three days till you we the American
people that you will have the ultimate
decision you'll be the ultimate jury
well the ever weak forgetful Joe Biden
has been in public life for over 50
years soul in five decades he must have
come up with a plan he must have done
things right well the mob and the media
won't lever tell you we might never know
by the way because well week Joe Biden
the forgetful one has not held a press
conference in 82 days the media mob of
course aiding and abetting and
protecting fragile Joe just like they
did Hillary in 2016 that's right after
82 days Joe has been mostly hiding in
his basement bunker but that by the way
that pleases Terry McAuliffe I'm fine
with him in the basement he only sees
two people at days two body people he's
gonna run for president we're gonna vote
in 133 days pretty much he's all but
shut off from the outside world
not weighing in on the big issues of the
day instead of taking any questions from
reporters he conducts what are these pre
scripted and frankly pathetic podcasts
which he somehow manages
to even botch over again and again and
again and again no outrage from the
media mob he gets a pass predictably
they do this often president Trump if he
goes a few seconds or days without
taking questions they have a collective
meltdown Joe Biden can actually go 82
days no questions no no media pretty
much at all only friendly media that's
because their shielding Joe Biden they
know it because President Trump well he
did issue police reform guidelines now
Joe was vice president eight years he
never did that and by the way they we
now know as presidents from he's the one
that passed criminal justice and prison
reform that wasn't Barack and that
wasn't Joe in fact Senate Democrats are
now stalling reform efforts in the
Senate tonight as we speak they know it
was President Trump also he's the one
that expanded funding and commitment on
unprecedented commitment for
historically black colleges in America
it wasn't Joe Biden and it wasn't Barack
Obama and they didn't know also was
President Trump he created Economic
Opportunity Zones in struggling
neighborhoods he talked about all of
this in his speech tonight
it wasn't Barack and it wasn't Joe and
Joe again five decades in government
Trump less than four years and of course
the media mob also very worried that
Biden can't actually answer tough
questions at all for example we know
tonight President Trump is vowing to
lock up anybody who vandalizes our
historic monuments of buildings in other
words he has a position he's taking a
stand ok so the question the mob and the
media if they had half a sense to do
their job they would insist on these
answers tonight
what would Joe do what would Biden do
does he support the tearing down of
statues does he to support the tearing
down of monuments what about the certain
monuments in Baltimore dedicated by
Nancy Pelosi's father and kept in place
by her own brother so tonight we ask ok
does week ever forgetful Joe Biden does
he support the vandalism for example
that took place last night
at Saint John's Church with be haz or
Blackhouse autonomous zone spray-painted
on the front of that church for
activist Shawn King on now he wants and
is leading an effort apparently statues
of Jesus tore down torn down because he
thinks they're quote a form of white
supremacy okay Joe Biden the forgetful
one do you agree or disagree and Joe
what do you think about Seattle's
lawless Chas chop autonomous Summer of
Love Festival zone you have any comments
about that and Joe what do you have to
say to the people whose businesses in
Seattle have now been destroyed in those
six blocks of lawlessness what do you
have to say to the 900 or so police
officers that were injured with rocks
and bottles and bricks and Molotov
cocktails what do you say to the
families that lost loved ones who are
serving their communities and protecting
them as police officers does Joe do you
support Joe the Seattle mayor do you
support the Washington state governor do
you support allowing a large part of an
American city to be taken over if you do
let us know if you don't tell us what
your solutions are what are your
solutions for police community relations
why didn't you do anything why didn't
you and Barack implement changes let's
see after Cambridge after Ferguson after
Baltimore and at any point in the eight
years you were the vice president of the
United States why didn't you do it then
and by the way as we continue our
questioning what would the ever weak and
frail and forgetful Joe do to improve
our failing educational systems in
America's big cities well what have you
done in the last 50 years that's a
legitimate question and Joe by the way
remember we haven't forgotten you fought
against integration efforts alongside
leading segregationist by the way here's
a question for Joe do you regret that
Joe do you regret openly worrying that
your kids could grow up in a quote
racial jungle your words Joe do you
regret authoring the 1990 1994 crime
bill well that's the one that led to
mass incarceration of minorities in this
country in other words the one with
criminal justice reform that Donald
Trump fixed and by the way Joe do you
regret praising the former Grand Poobah
of the Ku Klux Klan Robert Byrd because
he praised them a lot
also Joe congresswoman Acacio
tez well she's now advising your
campaign okay week Joe frail Joe do you
agree with her socialist utopian vision
you said you support a green new deal do
you fully support her version of a green
new deal no oil no energy no gas no call
and we're going to give everything away
free okay what are you gonna wendy gonna
replace the lifeblood of the world's
economy with let's start with that
question for Joe and by the way Joe will
you encourage businesses to move out of
China are you gonna hold China's
government accountable even though your
son zero experience hunter Wow he got a
better deal than even got in terms of
Ukraine because with China he got a
sweetheart 1.5 billion dollar deal with
the actual Bank of China and we don't
see any experience at his background at
all that would have warranted such a
deal but it happened shortly after he
stepped off your Air Force two airplane
in Beijing when you went to visit Asia
and China when you were the vice
president another question Joe may want
to ask is will you ask your son to give
up the shares and the investment of that
1.5 billion dollar deal with China or
maybe give back the money from verissimo
Holdings that he admits he had zero
experience in and got paid anyway I
don't know of no idea any experience no
none whatsoever anyway that's a lot of
millions of dollars Joe and you did
threaten to fire that prosecutor I'd
like to know your answer why did you why
don't you leverage a quid and a pro and
a quo a billion taxpayer dollars we also
know that Biden initially vast president
president Trump's China travel ban
remember that went into effect ten days
after the first identified confirmed
case of coronavirus in the u.s. well Joe
you called it hysterical xenophobic and
fear-mongering okay Joe what would you
have done differently because two months
and three days later you said you did
now support the travel ban by that time
it was way too late we can go on and on
let's end with one more important
question here's a question we need to
ask ourselves as a country in 133 days
does the ever frail forgetful 78 year
old confused and confounded Joe Biden
does he have the strength does he have
the stamina does he
have the alertness the mental acuity to
perform the toughest job in the world
well into his 80s now the media might
want to ask the age questions that they
had no trouble asking Ronald Reagan in
1984 well he we get to see all of his
medical records will he explain why he's
having so much trouble putting together
a podcast and two cogent sentences
without some colossal gaffe well the
media mob ever asked Biden any of these
questions will they even bother to
pressure the Biden campaign to hold a
simple press conference let's start with
maybe a zoom press conference now I
would argue tonight 133 days before the
election the American people deserve to
see Joe Biden Joe come out of hiding Joe
tell us where you stand Joe tell us why
you didn't do more in 50 years in public
life you're one team we got the mob in
the media protecting you but you know
what the American people I give them a
lot of credit and I think they're going
to see through the charade and again
another unholy alliance the mob and the
media they chose sides first they chose
Hillary now they choose you